una decina di anni fa ho avuto
l'opportunità di passare qualche anno
nella terapia intensiva neonatale della
Columbia University di New York Io sono
nanatologa E il mio desiderio era quello
di imparare di migliorare
igeamente Forse pensavo a un tecnicismo
a imparare delle linee guida che mi
avrebbero permesso di stare di fronte
alle situazioni difficili che ho ogni
giorno nel mio lavoro e diventare forse
infallibile non è stato così per fortuna
ho imparato tanto ho imparato anche
delle linee guida ma quello che mi ha
segnato di più è stato l'incontro con
una dottoressa la dottoressa Parravicini
una dottoressa che mi ha insegnato a
guardare i pazienti un modo diverso di
stare di fronte ai neonati sapendo che
hanno un destino che io posso solo
servire e Quindi niente Si è reso più
semplice Anzi è diventato più difficile
io appunto sono una neonatologa e mi
piace tantissimo il mio lavoro Amo
tantissimo i neonati partecipare a una
vita che nasce a un bambino che solo
perché c'è genera felicità
tenerezza fragilità e potenza insieme
che cambia tutto
e così il nostro lavoro di neonatologia
è quello di sostenere queste vite e se
ci sono dei problemi Cercare di
risolverli Quindi se nascono molto prima
del termine piccolissimi usare le
tecniche che adesso ci sono più avanzate
per permettere di crescere rianimarli Se
necessario in qualche modo salvarli e
vederli crescere collaborare a una vita
è bellissimo Potrei Raccontare
tantissime storie di pazienti che ho
visto crescere Non sempre però è
possibile Esistono dei bambini che
nascono con delle diagnosi molto
complesse che vengono definite Life
limiting conditions e la dottoressa
Parravicini di cui appunto vi ho citato
prima ha pensato in questo grosso centro
americano a un percorso proprio per
questi bambini e per Queste famiglie un
percorso che ha chiamato comfort care il
gol è il comfort perché questi bambini
possano stare bene
possano vivere senza dolore siano curati
e così accompagnati e accompagnate le
loro famiglie quando sono tornata in
Italia ho desiderato di portare questo
percorso all'ospedale dove lavoro e
Sant'Orsola di Bologna ed è stato
possibile grazie alla nascita di un
bambino di nome Giacomo Giacomo è nato
con una condizione inguaribile
normalmente quando nascono dei bambini
con dei problemi Vengono rapidamente
portati in terapia intensiva per le cure
del caso ma per la condizione che aveva
Giacomo le cure Intensive non
l'avrebbero permesso di avere una vita
più lunga di migliorare e lo avrebbero
allontanato dalla sua famiglia che tanto
lo attendeva
dall'abbraccio dei suoi genitori che
sarebbe stato il primo comfort appunto
per cui per la prima volta nel nostro
centro questo bambino è stato tenuto con
la sua mamma prima in sala parto e poi
nei reparti di ostetricia in sicurezza
seguito da pediatri ostetriche che hanno
deciso di dedicarsi a lui
in sicurezza
cercando di valutare se aveva dolore
cercando di dargli da mangiare di farlo
stare bene un ospedale che si è piegato
alle esigenze di questa famiglia e di
questo bambino e che da allora ha voluto
portare un nuovo protocollo che ha perso
il nome di questo bimbo percorso Giacomo
perché anche le altre famiglie con
queste storie possono essere
accompagnate e possa essere restituita
data dignità la dignità che ognuno di
noi ha
E così anche noi ci siamo trovati a
servire quel destino che dicevamo prima
perché la vita di questi bambini fosse
più bella
dove il limite non si può separare si
può abbracciare e anche gli operatori
che hanno collaborato a questa
assistenza è come se avessero recuperato
l'origine della loro professione la cura
dove non si può guarire Gli ospedali
sono nati così quando ancora non si
avevano terapie tecniche che potevano
fare guarire la cura e così in quella
sala parto in cui reparti di ostetricia
e se necessario anche in terapia
intensiva Perché alcuni di questi
bambini vengono invece portati in
terapia intensiva Ma è possibile fare
comunque queste terapie Noi partecipiamo
di una vita di una vita misteriosa
misteriosa ma di una misteriosa bellezza
perché è piena come si vede dagli occhi
di questi genitori che desiderano un
infinito ma che già vivono un infinito
di amore perché quel bambino è frutto di
un bene di due che si venuti bene e
hanno generato un bene che poi ha una
misura molto più grande di loro
diventare papà e mamma cambia la
consistenza di sé non sei più la stessa
cosa e i genitori di altri bambini Ester
Francesco Pietro clodin raccontano come
quei minuti ore giorni sono per sempre
durano per sempre e sono Anche
l'anticipo di un per sempre
abbiamo condiviso intravisto in questi
giorni un pezzettino di paradiso abbiamo
avuto il privilegio unico di conoscerlo
stringerlo coccolarlo per un tempo che
vale tutta la vita Quello che scrivono
questi genitori È quello che raccontano
altri papà e mamme di etnie diverse
culture diverse Concezione della vita
diverse e anche io mi sono trovata a
seguirli
a curarli a guardarli a stupirmi a
stupirmi di questo bene
infinito e vivibile è difficile
descrivere questa misteriosa e infinita
bellezza ve lo dico con le parole di una
lettera di un messaggio dei genitori di
Arianna una bimba con Gesù 2018 che ha
vissuto 34 giorni
Cara dottoressa Volevamo dirti Non
preoccuparti per noi siamo tranquilli e
davvero grati felici per tutto quello
che c'è stato Donato e per questi giorni
con Ari affrontiamo insieme un giorno
alla volta e cerchiamo di capire la
nostra anche tua piccola cosa vuole e
dove vuole andare quando sarà il suo
tempo La accompagneremo fino alle soglie
della migliore Eternità che si possa
desiderare il limite se non può essere
superato può essere abbracciato
[Applauso]